[Music]
consequently this spirit constructs for
itself not merely a world but a world
that has double divided and self opposed
the world of the ethical spirit is its
own present world and therefore each of
its powers exists in this unity and
insofar they are distinct from one
another there and live really what the
whole nothing has the significance of
being the negative of self consciousness
even the departed spirit is present in
his blood relationship in the self of
the family and the universal power the
government is the will the self of the
nation here however what is present he
has the significance only of an
objective reality the consciousness of
which existed beyond each single moment
qua essence receives this and with an
actuality from an other and so far as it
is actual and essence is something other
than its own actuality nothing has a
spirit that is grounded within itself
and in dwells it but each has its being
into the outside of and alien to it
the equilibrium of the whole is done the
unity which remains with itself nor the
contentment that comes from having
returned into itself but rests on the
alienation of opposites the whole
therefore like each single moment is a
self alienated actuality it falls apart
into a realm in which self consciousness
as well as its object is actual and into
another the realm of pure consciousness
which lying beyond the first is not a
present actuality but exists only for
faith now just in the ethical world
which is separated into divine and human
law under various forms and its
consciousness which is separated into
knowing and not knowing returns from
that divided miss into its destiny into
the self of the negative power of this
antithesis so these two realms of the
self alien spirit will also return into
the self but if former was the first
merely immediately valid self a single
person the second
which returns out of its externalization
into itself will be the universal self
the consciousness which is grasped its
notion and these spiritual worlds all of
those moments insist on a fixed fixed
actuality and non spiritual existence of
their own will dissolve in pure
intellectual insight this insight and
the self that apprehends itself
completes the stage of culture in
apprehended nothing but self and
everything itself that is it comprehend
everything when til the objectivity of
things and converts all in terms of
being into being for itself in proximity
to faith of the alien realm of essence
lying and the beyond it is the
enlightenment this enlightenment
completes the alienation of spirit in
this realm - in which that spirit takes
refuge and where it is conscious of an
unruffled peace it upsets the
housekeeping of spirit of the household
effete by bringing into that household
of tools and utensils of this world a
world which that spirit can not deny is
its own because its consciousness
likewise belongs to it it is negative
activity pure insight at the same time
realizes itself and produces its own
object the unknowable absolute being and
the principle of utility since in this
way actuality had lost all
substantiality and nothing in it has
intrinsic being not only the realm of
faith but also the realm of the actual
world is overthrown the revolution gives
birth to absolute freedom and with this
freedom that previously alienated spirit
has completely returned into itself has
abandoned this region of culture and
passes on to another region the region
of the moral consciousness
there is a lot going on here in this
long pier graph number 486 which is
concluding the the introductory three
paragraphs to the section of culture or
alienated spirit and I would say that
the the two main things that are
occurring is Hegel is in a very big
picture kind of way contrasting two
different world the world of an earlier
stage of the ethical spirits you know
what we traced earlier in this spirit
section we're talking about the two
different laws and all of that and then
the transition that we had he's not
going to talk very much about that in
here but the transition through legal
right and the Lord of the world and then
what the world of culture is actually
going to encompass so what is going on
in this long long section of the
phenomenology and then the second thing
that he's going to do is Trace out for
us in advance again a very big picture
some of the the key developments that
are taking place within these these
sections of this this portion of the
work yet to come through the you know
many many paragraphs that we're going to
be plowing through so I think it's
worthwhile focusing very closely on each
part of this this passage so he says
this spirit constructs for itself not
merely a world but a world that has
double divided and self opposed
now he's immediately after that going to
start talking about the world of ethical
spirit that is not the same world as
what he just talked about he's talking
here about the world of culture so the
world of culture is a world that is
double divided and self opposed their
opposition's within the world itself
their opposition's within the alienated
consciousnesses that are taking part in
the formation and the ongoing process of
that world and then there's also of
course the inter
action between those consciousnesses in
that world so then he goes back and
starts talking about the world of the
ethical spirit so the world of the
ethical spirit is its own present world
it has its world for it it got a kind of
sureness in certainty about itself
remember where did we begin all of that
discussion you remember how we ended the
reason section with these you know these
ethical masses and finally the ethical
becomes aware of itself and it's totally
certain of itself it's got you know
starting points it doesn't need to prove
laws anymore it's got the laws given to
it if there's a certain positivity well
we saw how that played itself out in
this it's ethical world so he says each
of the powers exist in this unity what
are the powers well the divine law and
the human law as we saw and the people
who are embodying or representing or
implementing them so he says insofar as
they are distinct from one another
they're in equilibrium with the whole
now this is granted a bit of idealizing
isn't it because we just went through
two big sections preceding the legal
rights section in which we saw that
whatever equilibrium was there was kind
of the equilibrium that could easily get
out of whack and that things were not
quite so simple as a nice you know
stable equilibrium we had the the vision
of that at a few points but we also saw
that no no that was not actually
sustainable that's how we got here in
the first place right the adequate
Librium did not hold but this so what is
Hegel talking about here this is really
sort of the self representation of the
ethical world making itself how how it
grasps itself so he says nothing has the
significance of being the negative of
self-consciousness that's an interesting
thing to say another way of saying this
is there is no alienation
self-consciousness as a matter of fact
one of the problems
with what was going on in the ethical
world was in fact the opposite of
alienation sort of a complete
identification and knowing with complete
certainty exactly what your you're doing
and exactly who you represent and so
much so that the person who like like
Antigone identified herself with the
divine law could see in the human law
just a lawlessness or arbitrariness and
wouldn't give it its due right and
likewise it can say crayon or you know
the two brothers representing the human
law also see in the divine law something
that is you know really out of out of
line because they so much identify with
with you know their point of view in the
world with culture that self-assurance
when it is their rings kind of hollow so
over here we don't have something as
being the negative of self-consciousness
as Hegel says what are the examples he
says even the departed spirit is present
in blood relationship
it's assimilated in a certain way
there's nothing that's pure negativity
right the universal government is the
will the self of the nation the blood
relationship is the self of the family
now Eagle switches and he says here
however what is present has the
significance only of an objective
reality an objective reality usually
that we think of objective reality as
being something really good oh you've
got objective reality that's so much
better than subjective reality if it's
objective it must be true
interestingly from the Hegelian
perspective if it's merely objective
it's actually lacking in the most
important mode of truth it does not know
itself objective reality is in a certain
way lesser
than the right kind of subjective
reality being you know a subject so he
goes only says the consciousness of this
exists in a beyond each single moment
qua essence receives this and with it
actuality from an other insofar as it is
actual its essence of something other
than its own actuality nothing that is
actual that is view click really is what
it is entirely it's its meaning and its
fullness of essence lies in some sort of
Beyond and Hegel is going to play this
out in the as we saw in the previous
paragraph this this movement from actual
consciousness to pure consciousness the
pure consciousness applies it with a
beyond so he goes on and he says now
this is a really beautiful passage think
about what this is like nothing has the
spirit that is grounded within itself
and in dwells it but each has its being
in something outside of it and alien to
it think about the contrast between that
and where consciousness was in say the
Greek city-state the way that Hegel is
representing or even the early Roman
Republic the way that Hegel is
representing it or we might pick all
sorts of other examples where people you
know know where they fit and understand
the contours of their world this this
world of culture that we're moving into
everything has its meaning in something
else not in itself it has no indwelling
spirit that it can completely rely upon
and we might say you know we're talking
about the Middle Ages and all that we
have local communities where things are
like this like the Greek city-states but
something different has come on the
scene a universal religion that is
really you know it's kind of funny
there's a bit of a digression but if you
think about the so-called age of faith
or from the perspective of the
Enlightenment the Dark Ages right you
know if we want to think about things as
they really were historically as we find
them through historical documents Europe
never Western Europe never was fully
Christianized in the sense that like you
know the church ran everything as a
matter of fact even within the church's
institutions there's all these movements
and you know Rises and reforms and
degenerations and corruptions and all
these things going on at the same time
so things are not as simple as just well
they just all believed in something it
was the age of faith no you could in
fact be in some sort of organic
community and see that as being what was
most important but it was also possible
to exist in this sort of world of
alienated spirit so like he says nothing
has a spirit that's grounded within
itself in indwells it each has its being
and something outside and alien to it
the equilibrium of the whole is not the
unity which remains with itself nor the
contentment that comes from having
returned to itself but rest on the
alienation of opposites there's a new
kind of dynamism occurring here a
disequilibrium that allows for something
new to come on the scene so what is it
Hegel tells us the whole therefore like
each single moment is the self alienated
actuality the whole of this world that
is being experienced is a self alienated
actuality what does that mean that means
that for the individual there's no
losing yourself let's say you forget who
you are and where you fit in all that
there's no losing yourself in in the
world that used to be and an overcoming
alienation that way no because the whole
world is alienated everybody within it
is they alienated
so where do you turn alright so here's
where we go he says it falls apart into
a realm in which self-consciousness as
well as its object is actual and into
another another realm the realm of pure
consciousness which lying beyond the
first is not a present actuality the
realm of pure consciousness and again
don't don't associate this yet with you
know like conch and pure reason or any
sort of transcendental thing like that
pure consciousness you know in this case
means something more like the divine
something like what we attribute to God
or other divine beings however you want
to think about it right but this is not
actual this is that something you can
experience within the world this is not
something with that you can enter into a
kind of communication with it has to be
grasped in other ways so he goes on and
he says this is not a present actuality
but exists only for and here we get this
key word faith or belief Glavin knows
what he says this exists for staying
faith of who the faith of the actual
consciousness the person who is who
exists who lives who breathes who weeps
over his alienation who strives to
overcome it a compartment of that is
faith belief but it's belief in
something that ends up being its
antithesis of pure consciousness so he
goes on and he says just as the ethical
world which is separated into human and
divine law in their various forms and
it's consciousness which is separated to
knowing and not knowing returns from
that divided Mnet's into destiny into
the south of the negative part of this
antithesis so these two realms of the
eight self alienating spirit are also
going to return into the self but then
he says but if the former was the first
me
we immediately val itself the single
person this second realm something new
here but the single person who he got in
the transition of course the second the
single person who returns out of
externalization into itself will be the
universal self the consciousness which
is grasped its notion its baguette right
and these spiritual worlds all of whose
moments insist on a fixed actuality and
non spiritual existence of their own
will dissolve in pure intellectual
insight and now we get a second movement
beyond faith Hegel thinks that the
historical process is going to you know
be this sort of working through faith
for a long time and then working beyond
it into something else something that
dissolves faith because it is better
than the faith it allows for the
individual to figure out where he or she
actually does fit in and connects with
the absolute so Hegel goes on and he
says this insight as the self that
apprehends itself is overcoming of
alienation right complete the stage of
culture notice what he says here very
similar to what he said in the reason
section isn't it
it apprehends nothing but self and
everything itself it comprehends
everything it wipes out the objectivity
of things converts all intrinsic being
into a being for itself
doesn't that sound very similar to what
Hegel was saying reason did at the
beginning of the reason section reason
is the totality of everything reason
discovers itself everywhere that is what
insight is going to do Hegel associate
this with a particular historical set of
movements which in German are the alfc
lorem and in English we call the
Enlightenment you know French has its
own thing you know
check the Lumiere so he talks about here
the
conflict that takes place a hostility to
faith as the alien realm of essence
lying in the yawn this is the
enlightenment the enlightenment
completes the alienation of spirit in
this realm - in which that spirit takes
refuge in which it's conscious of an
unruffled peace notice that some of the
interesting things he says it upsets the
housekeeping of spirit in the household
of faith by bringing into that household
the tools and utensils of this world
world that spirit cannot deny is its own
so although spirit in the form of people
and institutions wants to stick with the
world of faith
the Enlightenment is occurring and the
Enlightenment is bringing in all sorts
of cool stuff and you know the the
priests and and the other people
associated with it are like hey don't
bring that crap in here and the you know
the scientists and the you know writers
and all these other thinkers associated
with the Enlightenment is really quite
exciting isn't it the thing about this
are bringing these things in and saying
no no this is part of the furniture of
the world as well you can't keep this
out Hegel takes this as a decisive
development so he says in this negative
activity pure insight at the same time
realizes itself and produces its own
object the unknowable absolute being and
notice what he said that to this and the
principle of utility utilitarianism this
is a little bit of a digression
utilitarianism
has a somewhat longer you know or
earlier pedigree let's say then we
typically associate with it we we think
of it as starting with with Jeremy
Bentham but if you actually read through
literature from the Enlightenment you're
going to see this word utility used all
over the place Hume use is it for
example Voltaire uses it all sorts of
people are making appeals to utility and
when you make an appeal to utility
you're doing something that's very this
worldly as opposed to the world of faith
right there's no beyond we're saying
things need to be useful here now for
Hegel this development leads into
something again new there's going to be
the third section of this this portion
of the text
so he says send them this way actuality
has lost all substantiality and nothing
in it has intrinsic being not only the
realm of faith but also in the realm of
the actual or the realm of the actual
world is overthrown so what happens the
revolution gives rise he says to
absolute freedom and with this freedom
the previously alienated spirit has
returned to itself it is it is gone full
circle and has abandoned this region of
culture and passes on to another region
the region of the moral consciousness so
that is preparing us for what's what's
eventually going to be happening in the
third section which is you know very
interesting where we're going to get all
sorts of cool stuff going on but a
little bit before that we're going to
have you know absolute freedom and
absolute freedom is going to lead us to
the terror so that is why at the third
section beginning in 582 so that gives
us sort of a roadmap of where we're
going and an explanation of how we're
going to get there and why we have to do
that we're still at the very beginning
of this so we're still dealing with with
a world of alienated spirit we haven't
made any of these movements yet but now
we know where we're going